here's all the stuff I've been using let's
see how it compares to my old skincare routine
it's Michelle of Lab Muffin Beauty Science
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist and person
who really doesn't talk that much about her
skincare routine for a skincare influencer
with all this talk of skin cycling
it made me think about my skincare
routine which involves modified cycling I
guess and I remembered I made this video
in July 2020 reacting to my 2019 skincare routine
so today I'm going to react to my old reaction
video and chat about what I'm still using what's
changed and whether or not I still agree with
what I said like subscribe nerdification bell
so the problem with doing a full
reaction to that video is that that
video was already 26 bloody minutes long
so I'm going to be skipping around a lot
"I don't like sharing my routine that
often because I'm testing products and
I don't want to endorse something
that I haven't fully tested yet"
I agreed with that last time
and I still agree with it now
before I have an opinion on a product
I like to use it consistently for a
couple of weeks and then I like
to use it also on and off in
different conditions in different sorts of
weather in different parts of my menstrual
cycle when my skin's irritated when it's not
just to get like a really thorough idea of
how the product interacts with my skin and
when it really shines and when it doesn't
"I think it's tempting for people
to see my routine and try to copy
it exactly my skin's needs aren't the
same as another person's skin's needs"
"get to know your skin and its needs
then base a routine on that and your
budget and product accessibility"
"that's why the lab muffin guide to
basic skincare starts with instructions
on how to perform a skin assessment"
"you can't work out what your skin needs if
you're using products that aren't right for
your skin then putting products suited to
someone else's skin on top you just can't"
yes I still 100% agree with this I
am a big fan of purposeful deliberate
conscious skincare use even though those
words sound like really hippy-dippy
it actually stresses me out a bit when
I hear about products going viral and
selling out I really feel like skincare
just shouldn't be a fad and I hate that
skincare is heading towards or maybe
it's even there like a fast fashion
model where products and even brands aren't
planning to stick around for even a year
I think it is fine and natural to get bored
of your products and want to change things
up every once in a while but this
sort of artificial marketing-driven
over consumption is just not sustainable and
it's not good for your skin or your wallet
"I think a lot of skincare instagramers
tend to share their routines and it will
be like 10 products and half of
them will change every single day
I think it gives people who are less
experienced a misleading idea of how
many products should be in a routine and
how often you should be changing them out"
I still agree with this although
I think social media has moved
it's gone from photos with 15
products to tiktoks that are like
"you gotta try this product it completely
changed my skin everyone run out and buy it now"
from the sorts of comments and
questions I get I feel like a
lot of people don't really know how
to put together a routine anymore
it's a lot more focused on individual trending
products that might not actually
make a lot of sense put together
so now on to my personal routine
"my routine isn't rigid I adapt
it based on how my skin feels"
that's still the case I will pick
products based on whether my skin's
feeling tight dry what the weather is like as well
"my top priorities are anti-acne and
anti-pigmentation that hasn't changed
I'm turning 32 this year so young so I'm
starting to see more white hairs and wrinkles"
okay my skin concerns have actually changed
now with acne I was off the pill in
2019 I started again in early 2020
so now that I've been on the pill consistently
for almost three years my hormonal breakouts
have died down a lot I'll get one deep pimple
on my chin every second month sometimes I'll
get a pimple like right here because I
put my head down during pilates class
and I'm pretty sure that just yeah messed up
that area but yeah it's a lot more rare now
with pigmentation I mostly work from home in an
office that doesn't get much sunlight plus I did
a few rounds of picosure laser treatments last
year and with less acne there's also less of
that post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation so
with pigment it's more about prevention for
me than treatment now which is pretty much
just my day routine with sunscreen although
we are heading into summer now so the pigment
situation might change I do really like hiking
my wrinkles I don't think they've
changed that much I think the lack
of sun and that picosure also helped with that
so the bad side there's a pandemic
so I wear a 3M Aura mask a lot of
the time when I go out it sits off my
face so it isn't very irritating but it
does still trap moisture especially
when I'm teaching and talking a lot
so my biggest skin concerns
now are more with irritated
skin skin texture and superficial clogged pores
"my skin is oily and dehydration prone
I prefer not to layer too many products"
yep still the case
"too many steps gets confusing and heavy
and increases the chances of the products
interacting and clumping up or irritating my
skin and it takes longer than I can handle"
still correct
"after cleansing I like to use less
than four products I think the average
has actually gone down a bit since then
I think I generally use two or three"
I think my average is more like one or two
now part of this is also because I switched
to more multifunctional products that can
take the place of two or three products
"I don't like things that are unpleasant to
use even if they're more effective I like
to enjoy my skincare routine I favour products
with convenient packaging and easy application
over things that are a pain to use still true
I also like Pleasant textures and scents yes"
I think my preferences for skin care are pretty
solidly set now and I think that does come with
just getting older and being less money
poor but more time poor and energy poor
I also got diagnosed with ADHD and that's
part of why I find it difficult to stick
to routines if there's bad textures or
weird scents or fiddly packaging they're
all just like giant barriers to me using a product
"just because I don't regularly use a
product I've loved in the past doesn't
mean I no longer recommend it sometimes
products just fall by the wayside as a
similar product has replaced it and I
haven't felt the need to repurchase it
sometimes I switch to a different product and
forgotten how good it was and then later on I
rediscover it and go on a rave I think
that is going to happen in this video"
yeah and I just try so many products I have a
bad memory I just forget about things if I put
them away plus I think I've been in the process
of slowly replacing single function products
with more multifunctional ones or products
with nicer textures or packaging or whatever
I've tried so many products now in every
category there's probably at least three
or four products that are all really great
so which one I've been using at a particular
time might be something super trivial like
this fits in my bathroom cabinet better
so this is going to be more like a snapshot
of what I'm currently using rather than
my favourite products of all time or
even my favourite products currently
so the first step of my routine which is like
the same as everyone probably is cleansing
"last year I cleansed with an oil cleanser
then a gentle foaming cleanser I shower at
night so I step into the shower with oil
cleanse on my face then just step into the
shower for the foaming cleanser that's still
pretty much my routine even during lockdown"
this has changed a bit I mostly shower in
the morning or afternoon now so my hair can
air dry as much as possible before
I go to sleep because less effort
I try to wear as little makeup as possible
if I'm going to be wearing a mask which is
most of the time that I go out and that's
to reduce breakouts and also so I can keep
my mask less gross so that means I only
really use cleansing balms after filming
when I have a full proper face of
makeup probably about once a week
"this is the cleansing balm I've been using it
is that then I met you living cleansing balm"
I still love this it's still my
top cleansing balm of all time
also a disclaimer almost all the
products I'll be mentioning are PR
samples which are products that I've been
sent with no obligation to talk about them
I get sent a lot more products than I can
try out and almost all the brands that I like
and would buy offer to send me products it's
just how beauty marketing works at the moment
"the other cleansing balm I've been
using is the ordinary squalene cleanser"
this is still my top budget friendly
recommendation but I haven't used it
in a while because I've been trying
out so many other cleansing balms
I have actually found a few more to
join then I Met You in my favorites
the alpha H cleansing balm and
the krave beauty makeup rewind
both of these smell nice and are really just
a joy to use I have a pretty strong preference
for lightly fragranced products over strongly
fragranced and also unfragranced I think this
might be technically unfragranced but whatever
raw materials they've used smell really nice
"I've been using the then I met
you soothing tea cleansing gel
the Neutrogena Ultra Gentle daily cleanser
the bio Essence bio-water micellar water"
I haven't really been consistently
using any specific wash off cleansers
lately here are the ones I've
been using if you're curious
The Geek and gorgeous jelly Joker cleanser this
is really nice for a non-foaming cleanser really
gentle but I think I just need a little
fragrance in a cleanser to really love it
this is the iunik centella bubble
cleansing foam I really like the
self-foaming pumps this has like a bit of a
herbal scent it's really gentle and hydrating
I've also been using the CeraVe salicylic
acid cleanser this is really popular I
recommended it to my friend as like an easy
to find salicylic acid cleanser and then I
realised I hadn't actually tried it it's
fine it's not really giving me that much
of a difference on my skin and it might just be
because I'm already using so much salicylic acid
so I use these foaming cleansers in the
shower I hate washing my face over the
sink I've talked about this before I
hate how the water goes everywhere and
I have to wipe it down afterwards
I hate how it runs down my arms
so because of how my shower
routine's changed that means
that I've actually been using micellar water a lot
so the bioderma sensibio micellar water is my
favorite I think I've gone through maybe three
bottles and this one is half done I've raved about
this a whole bunch before so pretty much any time
I'm washing my face outside of the shower this is
it and I end up using this probably most nights
you don't have to rinse it afterwards
it was specifically designed for people
who are in places where the tap
water is not good for their skin
for makeup removal I've been
using this which is new it's
the bioderma two-phase sensibio eye makeup remover
a little bit disappointingly the water phase isn't
exactly the same as the standard micellar water
for both of these I use reusable
cotton rounds there's the velvet
sort of texture ones for the eyes and
I use a terry cloth texture for my face
I love how soft these are compared to the
disposable rounds I was using before and
I just chuck them into a mesh bag
and then put them in the laundry
I'm still using the bambu ones that
talked about before and it's got this
like handy tag to clip for drying
I've also started using the medik8 ones a lot more
and I love these because one side is terry cloth
and the other side is Velvet so I can just use
one for both my eyes and my face and then chuck
it in the wash whereas with the double-sided ones
I feel like I need to use it over a few nights
I've also tried these Garnier ones but I
don't like them as much they're like a bit
fluffy and the two sides separate a bit
more and yeah just a personal preference
and I don't think this is that much
cheaper than other reusable rounds
okay on to actives
"so I use a three night cycle for my leave on
evening products tretinoin night Alpha
hydroxy acid night and vitamin C night"
"I still use a three night cycle
tretinoin night is always in there
the other two nights have changed
a bit but generally there will be
one harsh exfoliating night and one
gentle nicer night recovery night"
"last year I said that my skin was still super
sensitive to tretinoin so thankfully it is a lot
less sensitive now I hardly ever get massive
peeling I still only use it every three days"
so yeah skin cycling is trending but it isn't
actually anything new cycling is really just not
using every single product every night which
has always been the case if you followed the
instructions on a lot of skincare products
that said use twice a week so I was doing it
before 2019 I'm sure people were doing
it as long as skincare has been around
okay so I went down this very very deep
rabbit hole looking for historical evidence
of people's skin cycling or just not using
products every single day and this is what
I found someone was using milk baths twice a
week so she was cycling her milk baths I guess
I even asked a archaeological expert who has
been digging into historical skin care and
she found that in ancient times people tended
to talk about products that maybe you wouldn't
use every day because they were quite harsh but
there wasn't any actual written evidence of how
frequently people use them but yeah so that was a
good six hours and I thought I would record this
so I haven't just completely wasted six hours
with nothing to show for it so yeah six hours
with the official skin cycle it recommends
one night for exfoliating then one night for
retinoids and then two nights for hydration
and soothing I was doing something similar
but with retinoids as the first night
then exfoliation and then one rest night
I actually think most people could work up
to using a retinoid every night or every
other night even with my three night cycle
I felt like I wasn't using retinoids enough
most of the studies on the benefits of
retinoids use nightly use there are a few
where retinoids were used every second night
and then maybe two studies where retinoids
were used twice a week or even once a
week and from the studies that looked
at frequency of use it seems like that the
more you use them the more benefits you get
the reason I wasn't using them as often
was because of that irritation and flaking
and I found that my skin was most irritated
two nights after using tretinoin so that's
why exfoliation was on the other night
to avoid that stinging so I was up to
comfortably using it every third night
and then the supply chain crisis hit
so I didn't actually have tretinoin for
about six months so I tried out a lot
of other retinoid products instead
and these ones were my favorites
the medik8 crystal retinal this is my favorite
retinal product I've been seeing more retinal on
the market and a lot of other retinal products are
really bright yellow which like they'll still work
but it's just a bit off-putting because you can
actually see it on your skin or at least I could
🎵piss 🎵
of the newer yellow ones this one was probably
my favorite the trinny retinal niacinamide serum
if you're looking for a budget friendly
retinal the Geek and gorgeous a-game is
the most budget-friendly one I've seen I feel like
it doesn't really make my skin look as nice as the
other retinal products and I think that's because
it's just got less supporting ingredients but this
is a good option if you just want to try a retinal
and yeah you don't want to spend too much money
I also really like night shift from stratia
this has encapsulated retinol and I did a
sponsored Instagram post explaining
why it was good so it's more stable
and more gentle they have studies on the raw
encapsulated retinol ingredient that they
used as well as on the finished product
so I really like this it's got a really
moisturizing base and it just works really
well it's like an all-in-one retinol product
I also really like the Paula's Choice
0.3% retinol and 2% bakuchiol this is
again another really good all-in-one product
Paula's Choice like to jam in all of
the supporting ingredients into their
products which is really good if you like
to have one step so this one has peptides
vitamin C skin soothing ingredients
antioxidants I think if I wanted
like a really really simple routine I
could even just use this every night
here is another all-in-one product the
StriVectin Super C retinol this one has
vitamin A B and C and so again it's just
like a no-brainer sort of product where
you don't have to think too hard and
you still get like three actors without
worrying about layering and how much to use
and all of that you just slap one thing on
the only thing I don't like about this
is that it isn't a dropper bottle and
yeah dropper bottles are just a little
bit more effort for me to use again like
the reasons I use the product are
just so trivial a lot of the time
so after all of that I am back to working
my way up slowly with tretinoin and I'm
being a bit more cautious because of
all that mask irritation I've been
getting so I've been using those
like cosmetic retinoid products
where my skin's too irritated to risk
using this this little tube of fire
so the random peeling from this and the mask
irritation has also thrown my cycle out of wack
so it's sort of been like a transition phase from
that three night regular cycle
to something different I guess
ideally where I'm trying to get to is
using a retinoid product every second night
so here are the moisturizers I
tend to use the most the laneige
cream skin toner and moisturizer the
Jordan Samuel skin performance cream
bioderma sensibio light Dr Dennis
gross's stress repair face cream
for mixing with tretinoin I've been trying a
few different things but my solid mainstay is
the la roche posay cicaplast baume it's
my go-to soothing cream so I figure it
has one of the best chances of stopping
all the flaking even though it couldn't
really save me from that half a
pea of freshly opened tretinoin
they've reformulated it to the B5
plus I picked this up in Europe I'm
still trying it out but so far it seems
to be working pretty much just as well
I've been trying out a lot of really bougie
moisturisers that I've been sent I've been curious
about fancy moisturizers for a while and since my
skin has been so irritated I've been trying out
creams with lots of actives rather than trying
out serums because it just seems a bit safer
so some of the ones um the biologique
recherche creme iso placenta that then
I met you renewing rich beauty cream which has
ginseng in it the sulwhasoo essential comfort
firming cream this is like a fiddy snails
favorite brand that I've been influenced by
Jude talks about this all the time so yeah
I thought I'd try some of their products
there's also the Emma lewisham Supernatural
cream which I really like and the augustinus
bader cream which I think I just keep
seeing in lots of beauty magazines
these creams do seem to do more than cheaper
moisturizers but I haven't really made up my
mind about them yet I'm not entirely sure that you
couldn't get a similar effect more cheaply with a
serum plus a moisturizer so to me they seem like
a nice treat yourself sort of product or if you're
in my situation where you just want one thing that
just has everything in it and it's like relatively
safe and gentle on your skin but I still need to
test them out more before I really make up my mind
"if my skin's too flaky or irritated I use Kate
Ryan's Total Nutrition Night Repair complex
instead I tend to use this a lot on nights
before I want my skin to look really good"
this is still my favorite cream to reliably
give me this effect but some of those fancy
moisturizers I've been using seem to do that
too and the textures are just a lot nicer as
much as I love this and I've loved this for
a really long time it does have like a bit
of a gluey texture that makes it a bit hard
to spread and I think I've been noticing it
a bit more because of that skin irritation
so now I tend to mix this with something
else and yeah that's just an extra step
which makes me less likely to pick this up
"so night two of my cycle is Alpha hydroxy
acid night and I said that I still find
that I get some whiteheads if I don't use
hydroxy acid exfoliants regularly that's
still the case now this is especially
important if I'm trying out sunscreens"
yes that is still true sunscreen
still clogs the crap out of my pores
2% BHA liquid still love it still use it I'm still
going with this we're basically married now
we're celebrating our what 13th anniversary
this is my default exfoliant for exfoliation
night it just works so well on my skin to make
it smoother and clear out my pores and just also
refine that texture it probably won't work for
everyone but I think it's a pretty nice option
for people who have oilier skin and big pores
I talk more about different exfoliants and
how to add them to your routine in my free
exfoliation guide so download
that if you haven't already
so back then my high strength
one was ultraceuticals ultra
brightening serum that is still in
my stash I still use it here it is
this is still on my bedside table I use
it a lot less now usually only when I go
to bed and I realize I forgot to put
on an exfoliant I should have really
just move this to the bathroom but then I
wouldn't have like an emergency exfoliant
"Kim there's people that are dying"
"I've started using more p50 lotion
which I bought when I was in Paris"
I still like this but I haven't actually used
it for a long time because I started on the
p50 pigm 400 version that's what's recommended
for people with east asian skin that's pretty
to hyperpigmentation but I found that it
was like a bit weak on my skin probably
because I've been using exfoliants for so long
so I think I just forgot to go back to the p50
"another acid product I've been using
a bit more is Dr Dennis gross's Alpha
Beta Universal daily peel and this I
think it's mostly just convenience"
I actually just got back from a holiday and
yeah I took these along because
they are just so so convenient
"on night 3 I found that recently I haven't
really been using vitamin C and I think
that's because I haven't really had that
much post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation"
that is the case now as well and I
can't really complain but vitamin C
is a really good ingredient
for other reasons as well
I used to use it at night because I didn't
like layering anything under sunscreen it
was too sticky but now that I don't wear
sunscreen most days because of how I live
in a cave I tend to use vitamin C in
the morning when I remember which is
like twice a week I should really like put
it on top of my toothbrush or something
the one I like the most is the skinceuticals
silymarin CF this is like the classic c e ferulic
formula but it was designed for oily skin so
the vitamin E has been replaced with silymarin
the silymarin is less thick and
oily compared to vitamin E and so
it's meant to clog your pores less and
just yeah be less oily for oily skin
one thing I really like about this is
that instead of smelling like hot dog
water which is like that classic
vitamin C serum with ferulic acid
smell this actually smells sort of like
those kopiko coffee lollies it's got this
sort of like caramel coffee scent which is
a lot nicer than that classic hot dog scent
and the other option for vitamin C is
just using it in another product so
this one also has vitamin C and also the
Paula's Choice retinol also has vitamin
C in it so yeah one less thing for me to
remember with my terrible goldfish memory
"so on my third night instead of vitamin C A lot
of the time now I will use these bakuchiol reface
pads from indeed Labs La clinica's Essentials
hydrating and healing serum" "I've actually
stopped using both of those I really love of the
Paula's Choice 10% niacinamide booster I don't
know why I stopped using it I think I just forgot
about it maybe I should go back to it I think also
a lot of the products I've been testing tend
to have niacinamide in them nowadays so maybe I
think I just sort of feel like I'm getting enough
niacinamide but I'm definitely not getting 10%"
so I've actually gotten back into using
niacinamide for my break nights and yeah
maybe it's because I've been using more
Western Products recently that aren't as
niacinamide heavy as Asian products
so the ones I've been using the TBH
rebound this is a niacinamide serum that
was developed as a collaboration with my
friend Hannah English who is a pharmaceutical
science she is on Instagram as ms_hannah_e
this has a really long list of other
nice ingredients as well like humectants
ceramides allantoin centella panthenol
so it's really good for like an active
recovery night it's a similar sort of idea
to that La Clinica serum that I talked about
um and it's just really pretty it's in this
like pretty gradient pump and it has a really
nice texture this yeah my skin just really
likes this it's just super super benign
there's also the then I met you giving Essence
which is a niacinamide product that also has a
bunch of fermented ingredients so
spot treatments depending on what
spots I have I used Paula's Choice 4% BHA
hydrocolloid bandages micro needle patches"
I ran out of the four percent BHA and I didn't
really like the texture and I don't get pimples
that often so usually I just use a micro needle
patch overnight and the 2% BHA during the day
"I've gotten lazy and my skin hasn't
been feeling that dehydrated I think
because a lot of my products now
have lots of humectants in them"
yeah I don't really use masks at all really
although I guess when I have really irritated
skin I'll use a really thick layer of La Roche
Posay cicaplast overnight as like a mask but yeah
it's like really just a thing that I slap on when
I feel like I can't really slap anything else on
"exfoliation catch-up now I
actually only use exfolikate
for this a lot of the time is
actually an add-on rather than
a substitute physical exfoliation one
to two times a week I still do that and
I am still using a peeling gel the peeling gel
I'm using is skinfood's pineapple peeling gel"
amazingly I don't think that has actually
changed I'm still using exfolikate I forgot
to put it inside the box because it is in
my shower I literally used it last night
um it is the best in-shower
exfoliating mask I've ever tried
with peeling gels I ran out of the skinfood
so I'm now trying out this missha one which
works quite well in general I found that
cellulose peeling gels work a lot better
than acrylates ones they work better on wet
skin which is when I use them the acrylates
ones work better on dry skin if you use an
acrylates one on wet skin sometimes you end
up with like bits on your face that kind of
feel weird and tacky and filmy so watch out
for that I don't think it's with all products but
cellulose is just a safer bet for in the shower
so things I've added to my routines since last
time I've added a microcurrent device this is
the foreo bear I did a sponsorship with them
I also have a nuface that I sometimes use as
well and I've been playing around with
them and trying to compare them I just
got back from holidays and I'm trying to
get back into using this but I tend to be
a bit sporadic because I'm just bad at using
things daily and every night I'm a night owl
and I tend to put off my night routine until
as late as possible and then I have to try to
cram it in and so I'm probably going to try
using this in the middle of the day instead
I also realized last time I forgot
to talk about lip balm and yeah
so the lip balm I've been using the most
is the dermal therapy lip balm this brand
is an Australian brand it is six dollars
and it is just really good it is the best
lip balm I've ever tried they've got
a bunch of different flavors some of
them have menthol so if you don't
like menthol I don't like menthol
um watch out for that but they have two flavors
that definitely don't probably more um Manuka
honey and pawpaw both of them are menthol free
and yeah they just work really well a lot of
people who are on um roaccutane use this and yeah
it works really well for super dried out lips
this one from skinfix also works quite well as
well it's probably the next best one after this
and yeah I don't love their clean marketing
but this is actually quite a good product
so looking back I guess the
biggest changes from 2020 to 2022
my skin's gotten more sensitive and
prone to irritation but I also have
less acne so my routine has switched
to more focus on soothing products
and gentler retinoids and that's
also because I ran out of tretinoin
my cleansing has also changed a bit because of
when I shower but conceptually my routine is still
pretty much the same routine it works really
well for my skin it might not work for yours
I am planning to ramp up the retinoid use
so we'll see how that goes with actually
changing my cycle for the first time after three
years-ish so we'll revisit how that went next year
like subscribe nerdification bell for more
nerdy beauty talk you can follow me on
Instagram and TikTok and more videos should be
popping up around me if you want to watch more